prime minister Narendra Modi is front
and center at this Inauguration in New
Delhi the ceremony marked the opening of
India's new Parliament building
[Music]
friends this is not just a building it
is a reflection of the dreams and
aspirations of 1.4 billion Indians it is
a temple of our democracy which gives a
message of India's strong resolve to the
world
Modi took a central role in the
inauguration that many in his party the
BJP say is entirely appropriate for the
man who's led the country for nearly a
decade
in this case he is from the BJP but that
doesn't mean he's the Prime Minister for
BJP
is the prime minister of the whole
country but 19 opposition parties
boycotted the event they say that such a
prestigious role should have been led by
the president the head of state not a
man they view as a threat to democracy
you undermine the soul of the parliament
so badly
so how can you expect to leave a legacy
behind when you've done everything to
throttle democracy in the Parliament and
outside the parliament
the old Parliament building was built by
the British in 1927 two decades before
independence but it had outgrown its
role as the home of the largest
democracy in the world the new
Parliament complex is at the heart of a
2.4 billion dollar building project and
gives the legislature three times as
much space and 500 more seats
but Indian democracy might need more
than just physical space
if we want our parliamentary democracy
to work well not only will we need a new
building but we'll also need that Spirit
of cooperation consensus between the
ruling party and opposition
so that the spirit of deliberational
debate is retained
in March there were protests in the old
Parliament when opposition leader Rahul
Gandhi was expelled scenes like this
have prompted many to believe that
Indian democracy needs more than just a
new home Tony Chang Al Jazeera